welcome back to las vegas now it is time
to get cooking with manny bubby's
kitchen today
she's showing us how to prepare a
delicious farm to table style
fruit compote hey nanny bubby hey there
rocky hello how are you
i'm good i'm good how are you i'm great
i'm
excited to be celebrating all the
wonderful things that are converging
this weekend we've got good friday we've
got easter we have happy passover
we've got spring today who knows if
it'll be winter tomorrow but
we've got all this i'm learning not to
trust the weather here
yeah yeah i get that for sure so you may
remember in january of 2020
i broke up with sugar for good
i was done but last march
about a year ago this month when the
shutdown came
and we all went looking for comfort food
and sure enough
sugar came knocking at my door and i
opened the door
and answered it just like that old
boyfriend that knocks on your door you
swear you're not gonna let him in
but you do and then you regret it every
day after that
and so when i was done with that sugar i
have sworn it off and so now i really
look for
great desserts that i can serve to my
family and my friends that are
filled with the beauty of what nature
has the sweetness of nature
and during holiday meals you eat so
heavy anyway who
needs a heavy baked alaska for dessert
right
so what was there you go so what we're
starting with
is the fruits of the season now pretty
soon you're going to have stone fruits
and you could substitute stone fruits at
any time
for any of these fruits but these fruits
are the end of the season right now and
there were no stone fruits as of yet
except the ones that come from 10 000
miles away and you do not want to eat
those
so we've got three different kinds of
pears a bosque a red and an andrew pear
and i have already in the you know
interest of time
sliced some of them but what i want to
show you is how to slice them rocky
which is you want to do long cut them in
half as you can see i cut this one in
half
and avoiding the stem or the core and
just slice them
in long slices like this and just to add
some
extra texture and look and color
you want to then maybe slice some of
them in half so if you look into the
bowl you will see
that some of them are long and some of
them are our half
we've got one honey crisp apple in there
oh that's my favorite
yes mine too and i love the tanginess
of that of the granny smith not granny
goose but granny smith
and um and we're just going to do the
same with it
so i'll just throw those in and also
granny smith's brown very quickly so you
want to be careful so the next thing
we're going to do is we're going to make
a sauce
and it starts with jammer marmalade this
is a homemade
peach plum jam very low in sugar
marmalade marmalade is also low in sugar
you want to make sure it's room
temperature ooh
can we find one recipe on your website
as well
not yet i have not made jams or jellies
i'm making a personal request
they're going to teach you so in a
little bit yes in a little bit
so we're going to take this and we're
going to add about
three tablespoons of this room
temperature jam
like wasabi and soy sauce you want to
make sure that
this is your wasabi and this is
we're gonna take this on my favorite
chapman juicer
get a little juice we've got the juice
now watch this it's so cool i love this
oh my gosh i love that yes i love that
about a half cup
i need that in my life i know you can
find that on my website on game changers
and then you're going to add just a
little bit at a time
into this so that you smooth it and it
absorbs it
so it doesn't get lumpy so let's just a
little bit
this is a little bit we've got one more
minute to see the finished product okay
okay all right so there we go we've got
this
we are going to take these raspberries
and put them
in we're going to take the juice and
just put it right
over the top like this isn't that
fabulous
i've never seen i've never seen this
before
yeah well it's just because we're so
used to eating heavy
thick sugary desserts and there's no
reason when you've got something this
beautiful right so now and it's swimming
we got to get ready so this is perfect
for anyone taking a step back from
yeah you know season but you go right
ahead
we're going to put a little that looks
so good garden
and we're going to take the mint because
green always looks beautiful
on anything that's food right this is
fresh mint look at that now is that
fit for a king or a queen that is
anybody getting ready for swimsuit
season do you love that yes i love it
thank you now can you drive over here
and bring it to me please
you bet i'm gonna bring you all right
thank you so much
nice to see you all right check out
nanny bubby's kitchen and garden on
social media and online at
nannybubby.com we also want to thank
chapman automotive
for sponsoring this segment jc